[inaudible] all right,
let's talk about systemic racism or
at least the idea of systemic racism.
So I think you've seen the video of me
about two or two and a half years ago
with Larry elder and I
brought up systemic racism.
Larry elder proceeded to commit
a hate crime on me, a white man.
He beat me senseless with statistics
and I came to a fight not ready to fight
basically. And that was definitely
one of my red pillow moments,
so to speak. I was not prepared.
I heard new information.
I did research after that.
Subsequently,
I've had many people on this
show and many conversations, uh,
that have led me to two more of
Larry's original premise. Um,
so I guess first when you,
when you saw that moment, uh,
was that the first time you'd ever
seen me do anything? Cause that's,
a lot of people tell me and I'm like,
oh, I don't think it was the first time.
But I think,
yeah,
I mean I don't envy anyone who is
debating Larry elder on anything.
He's,
he's pretty devastating.
It must've been kind of refreshing though
when you saw this moment where he laid
it out and yeah. You know there was no
counter cause there is no counter. Right?
Well yeah he,
he what he did with you there is he,
he went through each specific venue
in which supposedly there is this big
systemic racism problem where the system
is rigged in such a way that it doesn't
require any individual in the system
to be racist in order for the system to
spit out racist outcomes. That's
essentially the idea of systemic racism.
So he went, he went with you
through, he said just name,
name a place in society where you think
systemic racism exists and he just di Ba
ba basically destroyed each one
with the specifics of, of the case.
And I'm not going to do a better job than
he did there and then he's capable of
doing.
But there's a bigger picture way to
test this systemic racism hypothesis,
which is to take two
populations where it's,
it's a very messy crude
science experiment.
But to take two populations where you're
holding systemic racism, constant,
namely black Americans like
myself and black immigrants,
especially black immigrants from
the West indies and their children.
So we're talking about immigrants
from Jamaica, Barbados,
other places in the West indies
and specifically their children.
They're American born children.
So these are people you could
not tell apart from black.
Like you couldn't tell if I didn't
tell you that I wasn't the child of a
Jamaican immigrant or something.
Right. And you find that the,
the thing about these is that these two
populations differ in many ways. Some,
some, some ways are very hard to
quantify, but they differ culturally.
They differ for all kinds of reasons.
Um,
because partially because the kind of
immigrant who gets out of a Jamaica
differs systematically is going to
be disproportionately intelligent,
disproportionately hardworking,
whatever the traits are that get
you from Jamaica to New York.
Say That's a cluster of attributes
that that makes that population differ.
But there's,
there's one thing that is not different,
which is they're subjected to whatever
level of systemic racism exists.
So t Thomas soul has done good work on it.
Back in the 70s, he showed that, uh,
second generation west Indian west
Indians living in the same city as black
Americans were earning 58%
more, right? So they're,
they're both being treated to whatever
degree badly by white people there.
Whatever this,
whatever system you want,
I suppose is holding by people back is
equally affecting both of them. Uh, the,
the Columbia. So sociologist van
Tran has a great essay in which,
uh, um, the, this, this
difference is brought out.
You find neighborhoods of,
of black Americans right next
to neighborhoods of black
west Indians in New York,
they're equally segregated from white
people. So it gets rid of, you know, the,
the idea that being
segregated by a seller,
living around people who only
look like you is inherently a, um,
a disadvantage.
Um,
it gets around the policing issue because
these populations are being police.
The police can't tell the
difference between a second
generation west Indian end
and a black person.
It gets around whatever level of
systemic racism is or isn't in,
in the pipeline with regard to schools
and you find wildly different outcomes.
You find, you know, rate
of high school graduation,
much higher for Black West Indians,
uh, rate of enrollment in college,
much higher rate of
professional occupation,
much higher crime,
lower right.
So this suggests to me that there are,
that,
that the role of systemic racism
tool to whatever degree it exists is,
is minimal at this point.
Uh,
and there's a whole narrative built
around the idea that this is the primary
obstacle facing black people.
And it's worth noting, I don't,
I don't think most black people actually
believe this because I mean there are
various poles to site here, but
there's, there's one from Pew that,
that asked black people without
s without college educations has,
has race. How has your race held you
back at all in life? 60% said no.
It's a recent pew poll.
Another Gallup poll asked his bias,
the main issue facing you
in, in, in jobs and housing.
60% again said no. The
A, a Harvard sociologist,
Ethan Foss has done extensive polling
of the black community and found that
disconnected black youth,
which are, you know,
black youth without who aren't in
schools and don't have the jobs.
The people on the lowest rung of society
may something something around 30% of
them think the system is
rigged and 70% don't. So what,
what we're getting is we're getting the
voices of black people who believe the
systemic racism narrative promoted to the,
to the most powerful media
positions in our country.
So we're getting the impression that
this is a uniform view and it's not
right. So this is sort of
the Jesse Jackson's Al Sharp.
They get moved up because they're
given sort of simple answers. Right.
So I guess it, it hearkens the question
then I can ask this either way.
What is it that the west Indian
immigrants are doing right?
Or what is it that the other
folks are doing wrong? Yeah,
I mean you can answer that in either
direction you want to go first.
Well,
partly I,
part of it is just immigration selection
factors that I mentioned. Right? So the,
the kind of Jamaican or Barbadian who
makes it off the island to New York did
likely to be disproportionately
hardworking, disproportional,
disproportionately x for
whatever x factor is.
And so in that sense the direct
comparison can be misleading,
but it just analyzing why
these two populations differ.
You Find West Indian immigrants, uh, more
likely to come from a two parent home.
Um, you know, more likely to have,
have had a more classically
socially conservative upbringing,
which is, you know, you don't talk back to
your parents. Parents are rather strict.
There are downsides of course
to that style of parenting.
But um,
basically what I'm saying is that there
are cultural factors that are important
that differ between these two groups.
Right? And you find the, there,
there are many,
I mean this is,
this is where the conversation for many
people gets especially uncomfortable,
right?
It's the idea that every culture,
every subculture is identical in the
behave behavioral patterns that are
inculcated and wherever there is some,
wherever there is a
disparity in some outcome,
it's not possible that culture accounts
for some or most of of that disparity,
which I think is very silly idea.
Well, it's completely nonsensical.
Yeah. Cultures are different.
Different people and different groups
put different emphasis on certain things.
So I'm a little more on families
and put more on education,
so but more on sports or whatever
the hell, whatever the hell it is.
So when you hear Larry elder
make the argument, you know,
something around until 1972 the
black family had a higher rate of,
of staying in marriages and then he
lays out the reasons that he believes
policies of the Democrats
destroyed all that.
That that obviously resonates
with you. Right? Because you're,
you're giving me some piece of this.
Both answers I think resonate or went
back to family rates of marriage and some
sort of conservative ideals. Right?
Well, yeah. I mean that's a very complex,
people hate when you talk with,
when anyone talks about this about family,
people just absolutely hate it.
It is a fact
that black,
the,
the rate of two parent homes and marriages
was pretty similar to the white rate
until the 60s. Um, it is, it is a,
it's a matter of scholarly dispute as to
what was the cause I think it's certain
at this point there was no one cause
welfare state may have had something to do
with it, but I think it may have just
been changing norms in the culture.
What, cause we're seeing the
same thing happen in, in,
in the white working class as
well now with the decline of,
of two parent homes to
a lesser extent than,
than has happened in the
black community. Um, yeah.
So, so I guess what, yeah, so I mean
we could talk about some of the,
the most important behavioral patterns
that are different between a black
families and white families and
Asian families. Um, I mean there,
there are some statistics that I,
I just,
I don't see any way in which this could
possibly be explained by systemic racism.
For example,
one is that if you ask 13 year olds if
they've had their first sexual experience
yet,
you get 9% of of white saying yes,
you got 21% of black people saying yes.
Right?
So it's more than a two
fold difference there.
And that has everything to
do with family dynamics with,
with there not being
two parents in the home.
It is a development issue more than it
is an issue of treatment by white people.
Right. I have another piece in Colette,
uh, called Black American culture and,
and the racial wealth gap where I talk
about spending differences and you,
you, you know, Nielsen, the marketing
firm has done, done research on this,
found that the average black woman is
more likely to own a luxury vehicle than
the average white woman.
Despite the fact that the average black
family has one 10th the wealth of,
of, of the average average white
family spending patterns on,
on jewelry and expensive clothes are
very different in the black community.
Um, whatever you want to say about
these from an ethical a, this is not a,
I mean I'm not big in
the ethical judgment is,
I mean I'm not finger wagging and people
saying do x, don't do y. I'm saying
there are,
there are entire books
written by respected left wing
scholars about issues like
wealth or income or that just don't
mention a single one of these facts as if
it's not relevant. Right. So what's the,
what's the through line then or the
connection between all of this and the
welfare state? Because the more
that I've explored these ideas,
the more that I am starting to buy that
that almost is the real problem here
that we've given a certain amount
and then it's just human nature.
People don't want to stop being on the
Dole. That has nothing to do with race.
You could give it to anyone.
But in this case,
we happen be talking
about black Americans,
but I can give you just one simple
example, which is my sister lives in a,
in Manhattan,
not that far from you actually,
and she's in a building
that's part subsidized.
So there's a lot of black people in
the building that had been there for
generations now that are,
they're subsidized. My sister
and her husband, two kids,
they're not rolling in dough.
They're paying full market price.
But the people that are
in the subsidized housing,
it's almost impossible for them to leave.
I don't even blame them because
they're paying next to nothing.
And if they wanted to work more, they'd
probably, and then get off the subsidies.
The subsidies,
they probably have to leave the building
in the first place and then go live
somewhere worse. So we end up with
this horrific catch 22 that again,
I don't believe,
I don't put this on race.
It just seems to be affecting
people of a certain race more.
Yes. I think, I mean,
I think it's clear that
there was a point in, in,
in the late sixties and seventies
where the welfare state was clearly
incentivizing counterproductive behavior
disproportionately among black people.
Um, I mean, the reason I,
yeah, I, I, I, I don't,
I think we need a welfare state.
I think there's,
there's really no free market.
There's no capitalist economy in the world
that doesn't have one because they're
just,
and you know,
people's jobs are being taken by
automation and that's only going in one
direction.
And we clearly need a welfare state and
we need one that doesn't incentivize,
uh, you know, counterproductive
behavior. And we haven't always had that.
And when you say,
you mean some sort of social
safety net? Yes, correct.
Because I think people would,
you say welfare state,
I think people have a different sort of,
kind of
perhaps. Yeah. I mean as social,
I mean something that catches the people
who can't really, can't help themselves,
who can't trade their skills for
money in the market. Yeah, yeah.
I'm with Ya.
So,
so then how do we untether the issue
of people that are now stuck in that
machine where every time you talk
about it, you're called a racist?
No, I mean this is, yeah,
it is extremely pernicious because I
think it's clear that the welfare state,
the way it was rolled out in the sixties
and seventies had bad effects for black
people. Right? It's, it's,
it's hard to fully explain the decline
in two parent homes without noticing
that,
you know,
a black mother in the early seventies
stood to lose money by getting married to
a guy. Right? Because of the
perverse incentives of the
welfare state. That said,
it's not just because the welfare state
was one of the causes of the decline of
the black family doesn't imply that
taking it away would repair it.
So I think, I think that is something
like Charles Murray, for example,
grow big book in the 80s that
made him big losing ground,
which criticize the welfare state
very much along these grounds.
But I think even he has acknowledged that
at this point removing it once you've
said it all into motion, it's not
obvious that removing it is a cure,
which is, which is tragic, but
true. Yeah, it's, it's a real
tragedy because then it's like,
I mean this is where you would definitely
have a difference of opinion with
Candice. We're at her argument is
rip the Bandaid, rip the Bandaid,
let the pieces fall where they may,
I don't know what her policy is on that
and helping the poorest of the poor or
whatever. Like are you literally going
to be kicking people out of their houses?
I don't know what the answer to that is,
but I think there's,
there's a growing feeling I think at
least at a certain set of people that it's
not working.
You're acknowledging why it's not
working and these little bandaid fixes
seemingly only make it worse.
Yeah. It's, I think it's a very
complex issue because there are some,
there are some elements of the social
safety net that I think economists agree
are working like the
earned income tax credit,
which actually incentivizes you to work.
It helps the worst off
people in society without,
it basically corrects the massive mistake
of welfare in the Lyndon Johnson era.
Um, but yeah, no, it's
a, it's a complex issue.
Yeah, sure. So I hate to talk
about race this whole time.
It's like kind of annoying.
I know it's what you mostly write about.
What else is kind of on your mind?
Like what are the other issues
that you care about? I mean,
we can keep going on that, but I
always feel like it's like, it's,
that's also a sort of
tragedy of all of this.
It's like your whole world view is to
move past all this and yet because of that
you get thrust into the conversation.
It's a weird,
a weird psychological condition,
I suppose. Yes, it is.
Does that just drive you crazy in general?
Yeah. I mean I don't, before
we move on, I am racist.
Not something I find
inherently interesting. Yeah.
I think it is like when I have,
when I have a free moment to,
to read a book,
I'm not ordering the race book because,
but at the same time, it is a topic
that's looms so large in our politics.
And so much of what is said
makes so little sense that I,
it, it, it just gets to me.
So I have to say something,
but it's not something I enjoy.
I mean what,
what I really enjoy is a
philosophy and science. Um,
so, so when I have free moments, I tend
to read things in those, in those Janrus.
Yeah.
Well you're working for the right lady
Claire Over collect cause that's what she
cares about too. So actually we
can shift a little bit. So, uh,
you attended an event, uh, that, uh,
there's an IDW group in
New York put together. Uh,
it was put together in
like two or three days.
It was me and Eric Weinstein and
Faisal Machar and Melissa Chen.
And we're just kind of doing like
IDW one on one stuff. And you,
you asked me an interesting
question during the Q and a,
so I'll let you present the question
and then I want to hear your answer
actually before I repeat
my answer. Yeah. Yeah.
So my,
my question was essentially there are a
lot of people who really don't like the
intellectual dark web. I think it's just
a bunch of cranks who are, you know,
playing footsie the outright
in this objectionable way, um,
and totally dismissed the whole
thing. But then there are, there are,
there are many other people who
think, well, you know, I, I like,
I like half of the people in the, in
the intellectual dark web, you know,
I don't maybe like the other half,
but I think it's,
they have a kind of nuanced take on it,
but they're really where one
loses them is the fact that,
you know,
you've had Stefan Molyneux ma,
I don't know how to promote some
new Molyneux. Right. So this, this,
this character that people view as
objectionable to whatever degree.
I Dunno,
I don't follow him.
So I don't know whether they should or
shouldn't view him that way. But you know,
or Sam Harris has had Charles Murray
on the podcast, which you know, many,
he just has a terrible
reputation on the left,
largely undeserved or Joe Rogan head.
Alex Jones done. Exactly. We can do,
you can do this ad infinitum.
And it seems like that is is the last
place where people who might otherwise see
this phenomenon as good get off
the ship. Yeah. Or I've, I've had,
I think I've had conversations with
people where that was kind of the last
trench to die in, in terms of criticizing
the phenomenon. So my question was,
what do you like, what do you think
about this, do you think? I mean,
this is also a criticism that Barry Weiss
raised in her, in her piece about it.
So I guess my answer to that would be,
I'm, I mean, well, do you know
this guy, Daryl Davis? He, he,
he's a black guy who did a documentary,
can't remember the name of it,
where he met with the white supremist.
He met with Ku Klux Klan members as a
black person and just hung out with them,
talk to them about various issues.
Became friends with them. Right?
So imagine the psychological courage
this takes to sit across from someone who
literally thinks you are an
inferior kind of human being.
And to put that aside and just expand
your circle of empathy to include them
preemptively, incredibly
inspirational. So,
and he ends up getting over 200 Ku
Klux Klan members to renounce their
membership and he keeps their robes in
his closet as a kind of trophy of having
d radicalized them.
Okay.
And then he gets harshly criticized from
blacks, black lives matter for having,
having done this, um,
which is, which I find,
I find to be the most galling irony in
the world because we're talking about a
person who has done more to reduce racism
in this society than almost anyone I
could name in black lives matter, right?
He is, he is gone like a, you know,
many, many progressive activists, they,
they tend to go to the spaces that are
actually most progressive already and try
to make them even more progressive.
So they show up on the university campuses
already the most progressive places
on planet earth and then accused them
of being systemically racist. Right.
So we're talking about a guy who
actually went into the trenches. Yeah.
He plays the belly of the beast.
Exactly.
And was successful in d radicalizing
people from white racism.
Um, the, the point, the
point I'm making here is not,
not to compare obviously
Charles Murray or Stefan to,
to a Ku Klux Klan member.
My point is we ought to be expanding the
range of people were willing to talk to
and disagree with.
And I think that insofar as you're able
to challenge people or just expose,
expose people's ideas,
I think that in the long run,
as uncomfortable as it is and
counterintuitive as it is, tends to,
tends to be better.
Yeah. So I'll just repeat it
quickly, but that in essence,
that last portion especially really
was my answer. Now, first off,
some of us Rogan me in San particularly,
we interview people.
So we can't say we're for plurality of
ideas and we want to talk to people we
disagree with and all that. And then
only talk to people we agree with.
So that means we are going to talk to
some of these characters without getting
into any of the specifics of the people
that I've had on the show. Of course,
sometimes somebody you may not ask
the right question here or there.
I'm not even, I'm not even saying
that that's what I did or didn't do.
But you have like,
otherwise we're not taking any risks.
And the group of people that will talk
to will become infinitely smaller and
smaller and smaller. And
also we'll be sort of, um,
we'll be hostages to people that
don't like us in the first place.
And that's what I'm more concerned about.
It's like,
I don't want people who don't want any
conversation to be happening at all to
have ownership over who I'm
going to talk to. Yeah. Now,
on any specific moment, could any of us
do something a little bit differently?
Sure. But in essence, yeah, you're
asking about the gatekeeping that,
that Barry was talking about.
Yeah. I don't even know that it's,
it's for me to say. And as I said
before, you know, we don't even have,
it's not like we're walking around with
laminated cards and we'd go to a secret
meetings. I'm right. But I think the
best sunlight is the best disinfectant.
I just, I just fundamentally
believe that. And as far as I know,
no one was hurt by any of the interviews
that I've done. And I think I've,
I've helped a lot of people that were
maybe into some of those ideas. You know,
that was the one that people
were giving me a lotta.
That's the day I said Daryl
Davis phenomenon 80. Yeah.
Yeah. So, yeah, nobody's lost.
I mean, that's what I really believe.
And maybe that's a little, um,
rose colored glasses of me. But
I believe that, you know, when,
when people were giving me crap
for doing Alex Jones to like,
forget what he thinks
about things for a moment,
clearly hundreds of thousands or
millions of people are watching this.
I came on on a live show. I
said, whatever. I believe,
I didn't lie about anything.
I said the same thing as I say here.
And then I got emails from
his people saying, you know,
I never heard a decent
liberal talk before.
Now I watched your interview with
Bret Weinstein. So like, wow,
that's pretty cool man.
So I just think perhaps we,
and I mean you and I in this case,
we just have a little bit more
tolerance for,
I don't think if someone hears something
it's going to immediately infect them
and then they're going to take that
infection and infect other people.
But I think a lot of people operate
in that prison. I think so, uh,
one of the reasons I asked this question
at the event is I was glad you did by
the way. Yeah. It's because, for example,
Charles Murray has retweeted
some of my pieces and you know,
I've,
I've gotten into exchanges with
some of my critics where I've,
I've kind of talked them down off of
the ledge of me being a sellout or
convinced them that I'm,
I'm operating in good faith and the
trench there dying and criticizing me is,
well,
Charles Murray retweeted you and he is x,
y and Z. Therefore, I
think a, that's just,
that's like two layers of Ad Hominem.
Ad Hominem is attacking
you instead of your belief,
but attacking someone else instead of
your belief. It's like, that's a bit much.
Yeah, it's Ad Hominem twice
over. But we seem to be in this,
in this place now where people like lists,
you know,
the SPLC is making lists of people
that are bad people. You know,
there was this alternative influencer
graph that you probably saw that tried to
link together.
I didn't even know,
probably 10 or 15 of the people
on there and I don't, you know,
and I looked at the list after where
they're including me in this like crazy,
whatever it was,
white supremacists list or something.
Not only did I not know
plenty of the people,
several of them I have muted
because they hate me. So it's like,
like you just come together with
anyone that has walked past you. Oh,
you shook hands with that guy. You
didn't know who he was. Too Bad. You're,
you're screwed man. Yeah,
that's it. No, I think,
I think I was telling this
to you before we filmed,
but I think we live in a McCarthy
asked era with regard to,
especially racism, but
also other, other isms. Um,
I mean I hope historians look back on
it as that, but you know, we're getting,
we're getting people fired for,
you know,
for saying the n word and an
antiracist context. You know,
Papa John's for example,
the CEO of that got fired for saying
the n word and there was no pushback on
that. The Guy said it in the
context of an anti racist razor,
like recalling his,
the racist of his youth and the heinous
things they would say. Yeah, right.
And it gets fired and get, gets his name
taken off the gym of his local hometown.
Just gets his reputation deep.
Sixth and right.
So like this is happening. It
happened a month later to, to,
to this executive at Netflix who's in a,
in a meeting about offensive words
and Netflix is comedy context.
So how do you have a meeting about
offensive words without saying offensive
words unless you're just going to be
talking like alphabet soup and the entire
time.
So he says this fired.
So these are note nobody upon reflection
thinks that these people are racists.
It is completely,
it is,
it is analogous to
McCarthyism in that sense.
And the word racism has been
denuded so fully of of its,
of its moral valence and its moral
charge at this point that you know,
people, you know, we're, we're caring
less and less about actual racism too.
That that's a fear here. Like, once you,
once you strip this word of all
of this all its moral charge,
then you have a boy who
cried wolf scenario,
which ends up backfiring spectacularly.
And I would argue that that is happening.
We're seeing a, a surge, uh, on the,
on the far right as well. Right.
So I think
that that was also my concern.
I mean, before the election,
I did plenty of videos about you
gotta stop calling Trump Hitler. Yeah.
Because if he is not Hitler, and for all
the reasons that people don't like them,
the guy's not Hitler.
And it's like you keep doing that.
You won't even realize when
the real bad guys go. Yeah.
And the people that would be sympathetic
to your views will no longer listen to
you. Yeah. Because they'll view
you as the boy who cried wolf.
Yeah. And Bill Mar del Mar called
himself out for doing this for calling,
you know, Bush and Romney
racists or whatever it was.
Right.
He said that Romney or hated women.
Yes, yes. Yeah. And he called himself
out for being hyperbolic so that when,
when trunk Trump came along who actually
has done clearly or has said clearly
misogynous things is alleged to have
said some things that if he did say them
are, are clearly racist. Yeah. Um,
people don't care anymore because
they've been so solid. You know, they've,
they've been called racist a thousand
times by the pundits at Msnbc and it's,
it's been true maybe 10% of the times,
but not true. Like for the, the,
the funniest case of
this to me was, uh, when,
when Trump called Omarosa a dog,
right?
At Wash u turn on NBC and Msnbc after
this or are read the New York Times.
It is just obvious to those
people that this is a racist slur.
He's called this black woman a dog.
This is obviously racist.
And if you're defending it, you're a
racist too. Okay. And then you just,
if you have an internet connection,
yeah. You look at the other people,
Trump has directly called the dog.
You find Mac Miller before he passed away.
Of course you find, um, David Axelrod,
you find Adriana Huffington, just, you,
you find white person after white person
that he is directly called the dog,
not said they did something
like a dog cause he does,
he likes that construction too.
Right?
But he's called the white
person after white person a dog.
There's no reason to believe
that this was a racist incident.
And yet every pundit at
Msnbc is saying that it is.
And anyone who likes Trump and you know,
watches Fox News,
they're getting these clips exported
from MSNBC seeing themselves called as
racist by called racist by
implication or by association.
And then seeing someone like Tucker
Carlson who you know, I have,
I have reservations about,
but seeing someone like Tucker
Carlson make perfect sense about it,
just destroy this view with,
with simple logic and
facts and imagine how,
how refreshing it is to have
someone like Tucker doing that.
And obviously like you're, you're going
to get tired of being called a racist in,
in cases when it's so obviously not
true and there's just a lack of due
diligence. There's a lack of
any concern for, for facts.
And for logic and that
ends up having a very, uh,
a bad effect on the other
end because now Trump,
I mean there are some things Trump has
said for which racism I think is the best
explanation.
I don't think he's a Klan member.
I think he's a very mild kind of New
York racist of his era. You know, there,
there degrees of racism in other words.
But the point is,
it's like the, the reason that Trump
voters, I think for the most part,
excuse him, on some of the
things he said is not because,
or not for the most part because of a
random upsurge and racism that happened in
2016 but wasn't present the past
eight years. You, they're like,
there are counties that went for Obama
twice that went for Trump. It is, it is.
I think it's largely because
people are absolutely sick of,
of being tarred as racists,
untethered to the facts
of the specific cases.
Yeah. And then now we've got
just the match made in hell.
We've got a group that calls everyone
racist. The guy who, you know,
is happy to bite them on every bit of
it and use that as fuel to get his base
going. And Yeah. So what do you,
somehow I said we were going to shift
that a race and we went right back to
exactly. Yeah. All right. We're going
to try to finish up something else.
But what do you, what do you even consider
yourself politically these days? If I,
if I was trying to label you, I
mean I have a sense, you know,
you're somewhere in that classical
liberal situation, but does,
does that even matter to you? Do you,
do you think of yourself a certain way?
I think if you can be gender fluid,
you should be able to be political fluid
at this point. Yeah. I think, uh, I don't,
and I,
I find your political views to be,
I appreciate that. I appreciate
that. Um, no, but I think, I mean,
it is,
it is strange that is it,
like politics is a social construct,
political ideologies.
These are fully social constructs and it
seems like we're getting more and more
rigid with the degree to
which we take them seriously.
Um,
obviously one should take ideas seriously,
but I don't see anything to be gained
from anchoring myself to conservatism or
liberalism or libertarianism,
even though I find wisdom and,
and all of these three, uh,
political ideologies. Um,
so yeah, I mean, I think, I
think if I can, if I can make
politically fluid a meme,
that would be, that'd be great. Yeah.
I will see what I can do. All right.
Give me one other thing besides race.
What are you doing for fun days?
Man,
I'm reading, I'm reading a lot
about, I'm taking metaphysics,
taking philosophy of language in mind.
Both of them.
What are you doing?
Facetime, reading metaphors.
You've got a political future
in front of you or, Oh God, no.
And this is the of it, right?
People often ask me that. No,
I would never go into politics.
Actually. People assume that about me,
which I think is really
interesting because I detest
politics. I hate it so much.
Um, yeah, no, I don't. I Dunno.
I Dunno why I give that vibe off,
but it's, yeah. I, I cannot
see myself as a politician.
You're too sane. That's the problem. It's
been a pleasure, man. Likewise. All right.
We're more on Coleman. Follow them
on the Twitter at Cold X. Man.